breaking overnight to Holland America
cruise ships are waiting outside Port
Everglades in South Florida carrying
passengers believed to be infected with
the corona virus the cruise line says
more than 200 people on the two ships
have flu-like symptoms on one ship the
Sam dam nine people have tested positive
for kovat 19 and two of them have died
and well Bojorquez is in miami man well
what will happen to the people on board
Anthony we can tell you there are 1200
passengers and 1,100 crew between both
ships officials say fewer than 10 people
require critical care right now they'd
like to get them to a local hospital but
at this point it is still unclear
exactly how they plan plan to safely
transport them off the ship medical
attention they've got they're doing the
best they can but I think he needs more
than that on land
Jennifer Ellen's parents Gloria and Bill
weed are passengers on the zaandam she
says both have had fevers for more than
a week and her father has developed
pneumonia we don't want anybody to be
infected in Fort Lauderdale because they
want to land there we just want to make
sure that the people that are really
sick get help fast I mean you look at
this as a humanitarian issue it is it's
absolutely a manatorian issue catherine
Callahans parents John and rosemary are
also on board the sand dam you could
certainly catch Kovac but you could be
susceptible to something else so getting
everybody off that ship as soon as
possible is imperative as late as
Wednesday night Florida Governor Rhonda
Santas was reluctant to bring all
passengers ashore we just want to make
sure that the people are safe
Florida has the fifth highest number of
reported cases in the country and a
highly vulnerable population more than a
quarter of Floridians are over the age
of 60 I'm going to be doing an executive
order today
directing all Floridians to limit
movements and personal interactions
outside the home to only those necessary
to obtain or provide essential services
or conduct essential activities after
resisting for weeks to Santas finally
issued a statewide shelter at home order
Wednesday
if the
seniors and those who have health
problems if they're staying home if
they're protecting themselves then I
think we're going to be able to get
through this the governor's order deems
religious institutions as essential and
exempt them from social distancing
guidelines which critics say defeats the
purpose as for cruise ships there is yet
another on the way to Florida where the
crew reports a higher than normal number
of passengers with flu-like symptoms
Gale man well thank you